klassischer musik für kent nagano ein
großes versprechen
der amerikaner mit japanischen wurzeln
ist bekannt für seine besonnene art geht
es um klassische musik kennt der meistro
aber keine zurückhaltung bis zu den
inuit im hohen norden kanadas reist er
mit mitgliedern des sinfonieorchesters
montreal um den menschen seine musik
näherzubringen
naganos mission gerade die jüngste
generation in richtung bach und mozart
zu dirigieren
für die meisten der in ried kinder ist
dies eine premiere
vielleicht sogar ihr schlüsselerlebnis
als kind hat man noch keine zeit gehabt
vorurteile zu entwickeln einen status
quo zu definieren
die beziehung zur musik ist noch absolut
spontan
in naganos kindheit gehörte musizieren
zum alltag
der 63 jährige wuchs in einem
fischerdorf an der westküste der usa auf
wo sich einwanderer unterschiedlichster
herkunft niedergelassen hatten
das verbindende element die musik
rückblickend eine große chance als junge
hätte ich ihn eine völlig andere antwort
gegeben
ich hätte gesagt das ist so langweilig
hier aufzuwachsen
heute ist mir bewusst wie reich meine
kinder war
mit musik in kontakt treten sollte
eigentlich auch jedes schweizer
schulkind dafür hat sich das volk vor
zweieinhalb jahren deutlich
ausgesprochen
doch werden kantons hoheit harmos und
lehrplan 21 verzögert sich die umsetzung
um jahre
dabei trainiert aktives musizieren nicht
nur hören und motorische fähigkeiten
es sei auch die beste schule fürs
zusammenleben sagt nagano in großartigen
meisterwerken höher die spürt man
geheilt einen inhalt eine bedeutung
es ist eine der reinsten ausdrucksformen
der menschheit und bekräftigt dass wir
alle gleich sind
der dirigent und studierte soziologe ist
davon überzeugt in solch komplexen
werken werden grundgedanken und werte
unserer demokratischen gesellschaft
verhandelt setzen wir uns mit ihnen
auseinander beschäftigen wir uns mit den
existenziellen fragen unseres lebens
wenn wir uns dieser musik zu finden wir
zueinander und aus der grassierenden
sinnleere heraus
dies ist sein versprochenes wunder
classic gegen krise unterhaltungsmusik
allein könne dies nicht leisten
ja es gibt sie sie ist aufregend
unterhaltend wunderbar und wir dürfen
sie schätzen aber wir sollten
tiefgründige rissen nicht aus den augen
verliert unterhaltungsmusik kann nicht
alles um die palette mit klassischer
klangfarbe zu bereichern
verlässt nagano auch schon mal das
konzerthaus und taucht in die lebenswelt
der verfechter klassischer musik holt
sein publikum dort ab wo sich fast jedes
kanadische kind zu hause fühlt im
eishockey stadion
mit meilensteinen wie diesem in
berührung zu kommen egal wo egal sie
dafür steht nagano klassische musik ist
anders als alle anderen kunstformen
vielleicht schaffen wir es durch sie
über unseren horizont kinos zu sehen
einen moment